und paul ronzheimer der war natürlich
auch heute wieder für uns in der ukraine
unterwegs und er hat wirklich ja sehr
skurrile dramatische bilder mitgebracht
die aber auch ein bisschen hoffnung
machen
das ist die situation
das sind wirklich viele bilder paul
riegel uns da zeigt schwer bewaffnete
soldaten und dann plötzlich wie aus dem
nichts dann so eine hochzeitstorte und
sekt
wer heiratet sagen du hast gesagt es ist
schon jemand aus dieser truppe ja ich
habe sie noch nicht kennen gelernt die
werden gleich kommen ist sozusagen aus
dieser zivilen verteidigungs
einheitliche heiraten werden und so
sieht es an vielen stellen aus und
versuche jetzt gleich noch mal auch mit
wladimir zu sprechen dort gerade noch in
einem interview ist und wir sind hierher
gefahren aus der hauptstadt bleibt mir
ein
wort deutsch
kurz eine frage an dich bitte wie ist
die situation haben
es ist nach wie vor
sind die in kämpfe immer
die abstatt gewesen
es ist
ein unglaublicher bedarf an jede
hilfsmittel
es ist ganz wichtig jetzt
das westliche welt jetzt
schnellstmöglich nicht tage nicht
stunden minuten
sind intakt und es ist unglaublich
wichtig diese jährliche unterstützung zu
bekommen und auch mit sanktionen auf
verschiedenen feldern
zu markieren
die iss die das passiert jetzt hier ist
eine hochzeit die stadt natürlich ja
und jetzt gab sie die datenroaming
okay let's go ja die beiden ja wir haben
gerade so zu sagen hier einen einschlag
gehört und müssen jetzt hier wieder in
einen sicheren stand gehen
ja und gleich sollte trotzdem die
hochzeit stattfinden oder die verlogene
wirklich unglaubliche paul auch ein
unglaubliches zeichen der hoffnung muss
man tatsächlich sagen dass da so ein
mensch was passiert jetzt bereit sind zu
heiraten und einen bund für die zukunft
einzugehen haben wir materialien haben
sie entschieden wird und
die kämpfe gemeinsam in der ukraine
wollen jetzt
machen sie es hier mit euch als gäste
schauen nicht so schlecht
einwohner in deutschland was deutschland
tun packe ich jeden tag
unterstützen unterstützung
lebensmittel
sanktionen die kernel die wissen wo die
jüngsten stoppte und die schwächen
die optimistisch bist du das tief
gehalten werden kann wir haben keine
wahl
geheilt werden
in vororten heftige kämpfe momentan ja
ein wort zu kannst du stolz
stolz nicht sich gegen die als
bürgermeister vorstand haben als ich
sie war er aus füssen beim einzug kinder
dezember gesehen sie müssen um diese
krieg zu stoppen um jede art und weise
mit allen denen sie wissen es besser als
sie ihr dann irgendwie in deutschland
wie man diese vision strecke da fallen
wie sinnlose töten und ziemlich
danke an alle mitglieder und damit
erstmal zurück zu euch gleich noch
einmal hier die hochzeitstorte die
bereitsteht
das ist wirklich so skurril paul das ist
kaum in worte zu fassen aber wie schon
erwähnt habe sicherlich auch ein kreuz
und ein buch ich bin erst nicht so
richtig ausländer offenbar ist das
hier die traum bereits vorbereitet da
sehen wir auch eine kleine rede und
einen kreuznach der
orthodoxe kirche wir sehen natürlich
selbst machen muss jetzt hinter ihm her
einmal hier sehen wir die beiden kein
rauschendes fest keine freunde und
familie aber
kameraden ein zarter blumenstrauß und
mann und frau die geben sich das jawort
sie trägt ein weißes kleid er trägt auch
keinen smoking beide sind in ihre
soldaten kleidung auch die geistlichen
das sind wirklich
unglaubliche bilder die paul ronzheimer
für uns vor ort gedreht hat auch die
klitschko brüder waren bei dieser
hochzeit mit dabei